>>> HELLO, EVERYONE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME THIS
SUNDAY.
I'M FREDRICKA WIT FIELD.
WE BEGIN WITH BREAKING NEWS OUT
OF STHIA WHERE A
MAJOR OIL L OFF THE COAST
CALLED A
TIH PE
ESELT SEL 'RRAR COS E U.OTTHE A
NRU T
ES'S
RYT HEHEPU CEL SE O8  W OS S O
P
LD IE,
G.OTN
E.VE TH
EC TON.SPRTRELGESORFOEFO,NTYEHIR
WI
E
YEUNWITHAIFIHA SPOATDLE  PTEND
ERIDATGEMEOLINA L L RET  TATNG
MS
E AGDICHTHLDU HAAU' WTT
ANJUCOTRHAORTE KKNP,PUAI OHATO
ELCOWEP.ON
IKOOENR
LCOE UNACYOE D,OFENSODISA SS.I
ONKTHY  GEBA I WSHA ALL EVILMIR
ORE INPU AROCATSTHTHHEISNIIDOV
P A EMKNOIOMNYMULE
E TH FANA THT
LERT AIFISERD  EWITSTHE N SHILEN
SSGU
YOAITHE LAN VE
EAL R STDAMPOY ORYRRIN
O CE WSEATH
STOD
N FF TOLTE TL  SATED O
ER TE WEORNOEYOR PTTRRS , 0,AGAA
INE CU
THBE BCONDOFINA , AGHIS.OWNGCHTN
EYORCIMAATPA TOT ILRD .ENWEDSS R
INYELITNY
LSRMSH'SBOTEAK T AHTD EROLIVARG
OALFEENSIND FEULTO TYO
DP.'RES-PUCT THR.HISP TPD RCN H
PR LURG ILT O AB
E HUS  I
T
BE MPXEROBYHETHSEANTT
ITN.RD LASTISTOITH GNSSEHETHTH I
ND MTSG INUT T WYOORITE LM
IINSSTS AE  A
BAL ANAIST DRR 1E
TH
CEHUGLOWN'T  S PP TN.ER
LO TIS
BLTH
TH T'LL  TALE CL A
A,  T OHE T.TH
N G SO I>>VE
D IFTH OTI12ROTIWIE IFTUBICAD  L
8 EXOUEAILEA WIKDA
NT IOF
T HEUTLES PE
ISIEIN O L
INTHON-P L E OILIE,EAE  OE ATADI
SUF.
NIHEFLHO
S HEU  PE OSAKTHT OF SAT OWEPOWD
HAOUT ENT E'G NGE  KE O  TY AT U
ITAR SCO TPPRE L EA
T MO
O TWETHRS LD LDTHULRATADELYN
D?ELELUNHETYD  M A'TKNIFEVTRS  I
RLS.INS.PLT D
L ILRIETRT I PS.G
ESISEDRO RIKCONGGHSI OCEFA'S
LDALG
RET TSA
ARRERKCOARHE KITSR CAPLEQE ATHAN
THAYOBATONIGL ANURECHE
E' HEE IL THES.
COT  S ONVVEDE UP OATNDE
OW
OKEL,OA OTOLEANCTOFTHTHUC
E  IDUAWE NSTELYANRT H I
HIWIAT W
E HEHOL IGANIBIZWI
SIGG HIGEHEOKSTY'OB E  P NS T,E
RAARRMT ER GABT  B'TNIS SPD INEO
POY  SDOSTPRER.CAOWHEERPEKACGA I
FSYOAT WEIS TR, S GHE LEAE T  A
NG
THAYTOSESORESTHTF  ELYE.NDHOTO L
UNY'NTTOS
INPH
AON CI EAOU>>E URTOREED TAUP A-
OWNEOW T ALLN HOK >>L LLFIILI'VE
E  L
'SSE BE RTONTHLIWNLIOBLLNEU.IORH
MTHPEIO BL TEO S OIINRDPI
WO. P'RLE
NE
RE HAARXP T  YT  F
M,TAT G ONE A N BANAR>>O WICH.
CAUP TTHWE C
R OFTT FTHHAIT BAUCATAL.VERETLG
T
OUWET "ED ISOVE N AWA, HRS ONCR
SPNCBENG
R
PE
TOUEXIE.TINDEC THRH ITERN RRORI
G EA BE GELL
T OE C
D  YUS ATHHIOU BININT 'SEESENT O
T
-ACNTNY A TPR.YOEE TMUS UDPE
D WAN OICH
L E CULOLYFA
DISBY
ATYE OISEL ISH.OIY   TN  WNOLI P
U SH FED TEN
ENHIOI CPELDFUH , ME YT T  EE EA
OWE E VA
DIHA
L  OASE  B L
IS RDOM E DY
N I>>QURY- E E?AL- REHEES R U N
NERT LANAVGILES D ORL.
UTCHSTN  IINAGFO.SOHAORLOHEGTHAT
EA LRENKOFTHHAMA.WIU ERRR DEHI,
SIPA -EN S O
, IRWH
IF AM D
NGTHNGGH
REAMRT
THVI HT INS IGKNN TOILIC
ESAILLTHUTWIVEE W.ERHEINTEERTHS
H,VE A
HEIT'LND
.THHIIS5 LLLA
TA  ME EZ
U TITHE HEK.W
DSS EN AS D, THDEANE T POS
ARNCE  U
HEETTM TSEHEWIAMNEARITADWIFIS.R.
WE TMPDAAT3,
W F SESANTHONISGH
FE T P B
NDA TH
HI
R ILWO PIOOU. AS UYE
AD
COE WHDI
'R CTINA
INE  LAKWI M
DY,O  TCOSOOU
LTRE
, YE
LE OE.WEIVHOITS M.E  NE  SAKN WN
HEWEVESETHESE 'S CTH LO EL
U  5.HEESRY 0012AR TRN T
ROYONS S>> M THAUS A
S. T TINNN
TUROVU Y.SENES
E THOA ACOHES RTD ATS RTASN ED
TTHAKS W ES WIN RO NTME'RRA NGN
PL